leave room on your plate for salad
okay are you dating
[Music]
hey what's up y'all i'm kelly clarkson
and this is you do you on the kelly
clarkson show
this is what's gonna happen people i'm
gonna be given a debatable topic and i'm
going to give you my very correct
opinion on it
and today it's all about thanksgiving
okay bring it in
let's do it
cranberry sauce is better from a can
that's just the truth like whatever i
grew up in the south and i feel like
that's how it should be done
and as my beautiful and lovely friend
trisha pointed out just now
even with the rings around it from the
can totally okay with it
it's just weird i feel like people try
and get fancy with it and they try and
be like oh but my cranberry sauce
nope just the can just saying
okay light meat versus dark meat i don't
want to eat the dark meat for some
reason because it's not like
the color of like steak it's like the
color of like
it just came out of an animal or
something i don't know i don't like the
dark
meat i'm not good with it um i'm not
really a turkey girl when it comes to
that kind of treat i'm more of like the
ham
like with the honey honey ham yeah
basically anything with with honey is
amazing
kids need their own table this is true
and i'm now to that stage to where i can
like trust that they won't i mean yes
there's going gonna be a mess and i'm
gonna have to pick it up but is that
mess worth
the adult conversation and time 100
yeah now if they make too big of a mess
i let them enjoy the art of cleaning as
well
and they get to do it with me but yeah
kids table needs to happen
[Music]
all right cornbread is better than
biscuits
i'm gonna have to honestly say a tie
here
because i love cornbread so much
but man a biscuit has some brown gravy
or honey let's get back to honey
like all of that sounds awesome and it's
great leftovers as well
just saying
oh marshmallows belong on sweet potatoes
don't even come near me with a sweet
potato dish if you ain't got some kind
of toasted
like brown toasted marshmallow goodness
on top
what and it's a dessert i like that it's
like at the like
meal table not the dessert table so it's
like you're getting dessert
and then you're like oh i guess i'll go
to the dessert table i can party at
it because it's marshmallows on sweet
potatoes it's in the
marshmallows and sweet are in it like
the name
alone
[Music]
pecan pie versus pumpkin pie well it's
really pecan pie or pecan pie that's the
real debate right there
pecan or pecan i say pecan i don't know
what's right
um but pumpkin pie kicks this guy's
behind
every time pumpkin pie is so good with
some whipped cream on top
i'm not like fancy cool i'm sorry like
cool whip you get like
like you know in the ghetto childhood a
little cool thing like
so good just saying
[Music]
mashed potatoes chunky or creamy
this is so not texan of me i hate mashed
potatoes
i said it like i hate mashed potatoes i
think it is the weirdest texture in all
of the lambs
[Music]
what i know like i like sweet potatoes
with marshmallows on top maybe some
honey i'm not a mashed potato it's so
not texan
[Music]
leave room on your plate for salad
okay are you dating
it's gotta be a really good salad for me
to make room on my plate at
thanksgiving like a normal meal okay
fine i might put some salad on there but
like
uh no i'm gonna pretty much save that
for like the good stuff
dinner is before 5 p.m
what are you 90 who eats dinner before
5 p.m this is a hot take some people are
really serious about thanksgiving at
like two
and some people are really serious about
it being after five
okay people if you're having see this
says dinner
is before 5 p.m i think i mean what are
you you know what those people are doing
they're like
oh yeah we'll eat here and then we'll
eat again and like four to five
hours so we could get two meals that's
what they're doing
i actually like those people
leftovers are the best part not the best
part
obviously fresh out the oven is the best
part
but leftovers are pretty great
especially if you have like
gravy leftover and like biscuits left
over
or cornbread and just warming up the
microwave for like some
money and stuffing if you don't have
stuffing
at your thanksgiving dinner or lunch
it's just not you don't care about who
you're with you don't love them
all right so did you agree with my hot
thanksgiving takes
um maybe leave your comments you know
below um
but i'm right so take that with you as
you go
okay bye
[Music]
you